26 civils aligné au sein du gymnase où
maurice baquet comme chaque année avant
les fêtes de noël des archers de
billancourt organisé ce week end un
grand tournoi ont fini entre guillemets
la phase de préparation pour les bons à
tête qui eux vont pouvoir s'aligner
derrière sur les championnats
départementaux régionaux ou alors le
championnat de france qui a lieu
deuxième quinzaine de février
trois départs différents surtout le
week-end avant les finales du dimanche
après-midi 235 archers sont venus
disputer leurs flèches un tournoi ouvert
à tous on accueille les gens qui sont 10
sport on les classe avec mais ils ont
aussi une licence supplémentaire une
licence handisport qui leur permet
d'être comptabilisés dans le classement
national ans d'histoire tous les
participants même objectif toucher la
cible
chacun son arc et chacun sa technique
pour touché dans le mille
je chante en fait pour essayer de
vraiment de rester bien concentré de
bien lever la tête saunière droite etc
j'essaie essentiellement de faire le
vide est justement de penser que à la
cible et que
tu aux gestes à réaliser prochain rendez
vous pour les archers de guyancourt
l'accueil du championnat régional
adultes au mois de février